yeah it was just one of those things
where it it was done and they were
trying to save it but charlie sheen was
kind of the star he was you really can't
replace charlie sheen in that sort of he
had a nice run though yeah it had a
great run with him it's just
it's weird replacing a main character in
his show
with someone else i had to do it yeah
you had to do it
[Music]
we got it we all know his intentions
yes we are rolling hi guys
he gave he gave like seven i know that
was crazy because i was applauding that
we're we actually oh
no
[Music]
oh you do three snaps is what you do at
uh slam poetry yeah yeah oh yeah you do
the you do the
kind of
oh all right oh that's what he does he's
switching it up on me switching me up
switching up on me
that was four
one two three
do they start right when you yeah that's
just for sure because you know the guys
just like i'm sure anyone you work with
that you record stuff they like to talk
about stuff in the beginning so if i'm
recording and i accidentally put
something in that's it you know so
always make sure there's claps so we're
actually starting have you made that
mistake before no but there's times when
i didn't do claps they said we were
starting but then they didn't like
something about the start
something like that so you just yep it
reminds me of a dog trick you know when
you try to teach your dog something you
need like the um whistle the verbal
command like you tell them to sit and
sometimes you'll have the like clicker
so they uh associate the clicker with
the tree and doing the trick i thought
it was i thought it was the noise the
the caesar milan
[Applause]
i know he's been around for a minute and
i know it's like already been talked
about but i'll go through and i'll just
type in caesar milan videos on youtube
and i'll watch him and i'm just like
yo he eats
to some of the most brutal dogs yeah
yeah you gotta don't don't you look
doesn't he hit him in the neck or
something where's that south park thing
i saw a sidekick
huh like a nudge it's like a side nudge
like to redirect that
my only real
knowledge of him is from south park
which is he referring to and he would
like nip him in the net yeah
and i could take him home because she
needed to teach stevie and i all the
tricks that she was doing to get him to
behave
and we really just wanted to take him to
go get potty trained we didn't care
about the tricks i don't care if he sits
if he stays if he lays down i just want
to make sure that he is potty trained
because i couldn't do that probably 100
and she was teaching us all these things
and she has such a way of redirecting
dogs and such a command that i was
looking at her like i
i just don't know how to do that yeah
like how
how did someone get into dog training
yeah i don't know
but i see people do with the german
shepherds all the time and they got him
unlocked he was trying to get me to go
get bit by a german ship or i i should
punch shippers
um yeah and not you i mean it was for
the kids but it was for it was everybody
it was everybody it was brandon
mainly david lucas because that would
have been [ __ ] funny to watch him
yeah because you were there because you
were sitting right in front of me he's
also trying to get you content i don't
know if it's the type of context
brennan wanted me to help find content
while
you guys were on the road for the vlogs
hey don't you guys get bit by a car
bite suit on come on it's a fight suit
let me see the sidekick who are we what
are we doing here oh yeah we're where
cats have to dart
it's who we are
and we are here because we are here
because this is our way this is what we
just what we do our weekly meeting where
we check out everyone yeah we check in
together
uh we're the behind the scenes yes
you know most of us who are the um
what else we're like superheroes in some
sort of way we're like
class avengers like we're not the main
story i was going to go with x-men oh
x-men that's fair i like x-men right
because they're x-men it's kind of
outcast yeah the avengers are kind of
like
yes i don't know if that made any sense
it's a great way of putting it like the
avengers are the one that everybody
knows and then the uh x-men are kind of
like the stupid franchise they're trying
to catch up that's us
i love x-men
oh he's been my favorite actually i i
like x-men i've seen the x-men once the
the
cartoon was the [ __ ] oh the cartoon was
okay
yeah yeah yeah i remember the video game
uh yes that was on sega uh yes i think
it was sega
it was a good one it was a great one i
love x-men but i was going to say i like
prospects more than beat the term bt yes
yes yeah that's a great term
but uh yeah and then also we got a
couple uh guests resuming in today um
last week we teased are you smart
smarter than a uh actually sixth grader
we're gonna be talking a 12 year old
hold on
yeah
it's maylin all right it's melon
she's gonna make ap classes her father
uh nominated her and uh she's she
sounded pretty vicious yeah yeah she had
attitude she was like
she's a sixth grader right yeah i feel
like sixth graders if you're in multiple
ap classes you're you have like a lethal
like competitive spirit about you
because all ap kids want to do is like
outshine the other person yeah it's
about who's the smartest one in the
class yeah so i f i feel fear yeah oh i
feel i have a lot of fear yes if going
against this sixth grader you heard
you're the tone in her voice she said
it's melon yeah
it's melon and uh
yeah i almost moved it to next week uh
just because uh
george who works here with who we met
the the croatian george he croatian
george he was going to be make the game
but it's gringo poppy's coming out this
week yes uh so he's like swamp with that
stuff and i wanted to participate but
instead but he's he said we couldn't do
it the father said we couldn't do it
next week because she has volleyball at
4 45 so like i was like oh they're on a
schedule i was like if you want to lose
we could be still like make fun of her
because she's a nerd yeah but everything
she's a jock yeah yeah yeah so but going
back i'm sorry guys i think this girl is
cooler now yeah going back on what nick
said gringo poppy is already out by the
time this episode's out releases 9 a.m
thursday on thick boy youtube so make
sure you go stream it like it comment
yeah and the think boy album is also out
oh yeah that's got chappelle
chin jelly roll mike stud derek poston
uh little brows low brows yep bunch of
fun people on that dahlia eric griffin
uh bert so yeah big quit
slick transition dude
let's talk about it you guys that's on
the show right yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and this is by the time this is out
yeah
[Laughter]
and actually actually this week for sure
because like uh there's like a hold on
thick boy releases uh so this the audio
will be out
regular time whatever that is
and the video will be out days later but
so but you talked about it tell me about
it i i just heard about it well i um
i had been feeling it for a while i've
been feeling it probably since brian had
came back um
but i think just more so recently i just
acted upon it and was just
really feeling it even more
and uh
it was funny because brennan hit me up
he's like hey man we cool and i was like
yeah why wouldn't we be and he he goes i
don't know maybe it's just my anxiety or
whatever i was like okay i was like yeah
i'm not no no problems but then i was
thinking about it i was like okay i was
like if he's if he's feeling
if i'm giving off a vibe of something to
where
it makes him feel like we're not cool
then i need to speak up about the thing
that that's been on my mind for a really
long time and i think it just came even
heavier
more so recently especially as i've
you know started to do chappelle's world
a lot more
and i just really like doing that and
you know i i think yeah i'd be sitting
in a fighter in the kid and i'd be
thinking about
things of chappelle world the whole time
my brain would just be off on that and i
don't think that's fair to
those guys especially with them giving
me such a you know opportunity to come
in and you know be a part of their
uh show
so i just i was like i need to make an
adjustment i need to
do something i need to
make this shift and you know lean into
this thing that i
really uh really dig in and also uh
touring i'm having a lot of fun with
touring i'm having a lot of fun with my
band
and uh i think it just clears up
a lot of things for me but for me to be
able to fly away fun with
cats after dogs
you're saying right yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i called brendan that next day and i
talked to brian i talked to both of them
and just expressed
how i was truly feeling and
how i wanted to uh
fly the way i want to fly yeah let's
spread your wings yeah i i feel really
good and i'm
just really really excited about the
things that i want to do yeah that's
what i'm
really looking forward to that's awesome
you know so yeah i'm still cats have the
dark and still obviously chappelle's
world because that's the
you know yeah the thing i love the most
and there's no bad blood there's nothing
weird nothing nothing of that name
literally still in the same studio yeah
yeah i know
but people yeah sometimes would beg to
differ and think of it differently it's
like bro i'm real
next door right you know what bravo
because that's like uh
that's like a scary step because you are
like
you know there's like
a longer term benefit and like focusing
on this smaller currently smaller
project and you're leaving like a
platform so like yeah that's that's not
easy yeah yeah yeah 100
100
and
there was there were so many things
that led me to this thought but yeah i
really felt it when
initially when i uh when brenda said he
helped me out with you know creating
chappelle's world and
i just i just felt it and it's funny
because i called jay about a year it was
like literally a year ago i called jay
and i was like man you know
i wanted i talked to him first i was
like he's bringing his brother let me
talk to him kind of get his
you know
feedback or whatever and uh i was like
man i think i should you know should
leave and just really do my thing he's
like oh no people people like you on the
pod blah blah you know so he kind of
convinced me
to to stay but i just but i think that
just the whole time i was just really
feeling it and i and i don't want to be
there
and not give
100
of chappelle
you can you can tell when you just think
about something for like
like you've been thinking about for
months like you said oh i finally
finally just said it i don't even i
think we've ever said it on air theory
but like i left producing this past
weekend in the beginning of september
and it was like it was the same thing
like
cats after dark or king in the sting is
like a big part of my week i have my
other projects he's half the time in
nashville uh
i don't i don't think he ever would have
like got rid of me but like i was just
like this feels like the move like it's
almost like it's just a natural
progression and i thought about for a
long time and i finally did it 100 i
think sometimes you just got when you
feel
when you feel this other thing you feel
this passion over here
i think a lot of times you got to go
lean into that uh
passion and i think that's just what
where i'm
where i'm going you know i just i just
felt it and the name didn't even make
sense what fighter in the kit kid
[Laughter]
here's a here's another thing too
those guys have built a chemistry
together
over what a decade they've been doing
that pot or however long they've been
doing it
and
you know being being in that other other
chair
i admire their chemistry and what
they're able to do and what
how they're able to uh
create and just do this thing of of the
podcasting world and i was like man
i'm like okay they they have it they
it's it's their thing
let me let me go over here i didn't
create fighter and a kid i didn't you
know
that
like i don't own finder to kid or
anything of that nature so it definitely
needed you for for a while though like
yeah you know yeah and i'm appreciative
that they even that i was even asked to
to
partake in it the way
i did but needless to say i'm happy
about the things that i'm doing uh
the the touring you know headlining on
my own
is another
massive excitement you know i'm not
selling out you know i'm not selling out
shows but
people do come to the shows and people
do have a good time with me
at the shows and i just like i don't i
feel i'm like oh this is this is mine
that's what i feel i feel like oh this
is this is
something for me to hold on to
that's that's how i felt that is awesome
by the way you mentioned tours
can we announce as well that me
chappelle his band and little browser
were doing a show in l.a on the
troubadour at the troubadour tuesday may
17th so yeah everyone always messaging
me do a show in late
i said i'll be there if there's some
sort of list
yeah
so we have corey feldman actually
opening oh yeah
it's like i'm already there that's who's
headlined in that show i'm already there
he didn't say i thought it was a foreign
show and everybody at fighter candidate
has been nothing but great to me
uh
the whole way through so
very appreciative
of all of it
yeah but you're still here so you're not
yeah yeah it's not yeah i'm not gone
it's just
i just it's really i'm really excited
about things that i'm doing that's great
that's amazing you know my band's doing
its thing
we got shows we're going in the studio
to record a ep
so are you excited about that ep yeah
i'm excited how long do you think it'll
take before you can release it on any
sort of streaming platform i don't know
any of that process or how long that
necessarily takes i assume the guy i'm
working with i mean he's done work with
so many bands uh you might have heard of
the banzi's word metallica
we're just kidding
dude
never heard are you talking about this
already knew i was lying as soon as you
said metallica
i could tell if you were you were joking
then
cocky or he didn't yeah he did or he
didn't he did not do that but probably
big bands uh he's worked with corey
feldman
burying the lead
so how does how's the show gonna work
with you you three what's the like the
set like is it
are you gonna be out there individually
at some point uh we haven't even planned
this yeah my band's just gonna do just
gonna open we're gonna be the first band
up we're gonna go do our thing and then
him and little brows have a thing that
they yeah we have a bunch of songs
together so yeah they have a bunch of
songs together and they kind of it's
kind of like what you did in phoenix
where you guys kind of like blue browns
went up did did quite a few songs and he
brought you out did a song with you then
he went off stage chin did uh some songs
then he became uh yeah brows came back
together and kind of closed it out
together word and chappelle supported
big time as he hopped out on the stage
with us he was just like
i don't know like man
it's funny yeah yeah it's gonna be fun
yeah man i mean listen for
those who don't know my band is
pretty intense
and clean you guys are like really good
now yeah this is really good no bedroom
i told those guys i said hey we're not
going to suck yeah
i was like we will not [ __ ] see
you
name of the man
mad peaceful yeah that peaceful which is
something he's not what yeah i will
you know point exactly
you rhode island kids i thought you're
supposed to be mad peaceful i am back
that's the mad part but then the
peaceful part comes later
i love you man yeah yeah
i always say
what do you always say i say hey i love
you meatball you never heard me
i've never even heard you say that i
know right now
that was that was
it tough you huh you're almost no no no
saying that you love me kind of like i
could see it in your eyes that pain you
say it and i thought you were on the
verge of relapsing trying to get that
out
you look like wolverine
in a good way or a bad way because
hugh jackman
yeah
you know what it is it's the beard yeah
because his beard is really high my
beard's not high right now
no but like you could tell it's the high
you gotta
yeah it gets really high but it gets
really high huh he's got a good job too
yeah yeah the jawline or like
wolverine not he looked up
and i honestly thought he would come up
he looks like an actual
i guess wolverine x-men isn't popular
enough to come up when you type in
wolverine i guess because if you type in
pitbull the rapper comes up
who if you type in pitbull the rapper uh
comes up not just the dog
yeah
you gotta go to incognito mode to get
like real honest search results though
because really obviously christian's a
wildlife enthusiast
i see that yeah i do too i could see it
i could see it what was it what was it
what was his like opponent or lee
schreiber sabretooth which was his
brother cartoon that's cartoon knowledge
yeah
no no don't type in the actual actor oh
speaking of the cartoon i remember
watching it as a kid and seeing jubilee
getting so excited like oh there's an
asian girl and her [ __ ] power is that
she releases fireworks from her chest
it was the lamest [ __ ] that's what it is
you're more so saber-toothed dude the
girl i got a better jaw than him come on
[ __ ] fine right
the actress that played jean grey
she's fine that scene homegirl that
wasn't taken as well i don't know who
what her name is but
gorgeous i just put it together that
she's been taken but yeah that yeah yeah
she plays the um
yeah but uh yeah she
that scene was in the real one um i
don't know she like me i can't remember
if she
she's making out with something passed
out or
i don't know it's it's sex
wolverine right he's like sleeping she
gets on top of him she's making out and
she's like going backwards between the
phoenix oh yeah that's exactly what i
think
she tries to kill everyone and then he
like saves the day by trying to like she
bad cover the explosion and he then dies
in the process i guess but he lives i
don't know yeah he doesn't cause he
regenerates and he's good that
three-episode saga of when she became
phoenix on the cartoon was like the
scariest
yeah
terrifying
we are the same person dude did you ever
watch this other show that usually that
would come on around it i think it was
called california dream yeah yes it was
like a knockout state saved by the best
oh i remember that well they were banned
that's what it was they were a band yeah
and then there's also hang hang
time
with the
it was like a save by the bell knockoff
but they played basketball um but they
were saying there was actually the same
show type in hang time tv show anthony
anderson started on hang time really he
was a baller on hang time
it might be hayington
[Music]
yeah
no i don't think i ever saw this it was
awesome well the ninth girl dumped the
girl was dunking all the time that girl
uh sorry is she actually junking or just
there
uh
okay nick i'm gonna try this other tv
show with you there was this girl
hey dude huh hey dude no no
she was it was a real tv show so it was
right a reality show and she had super
powers her father was like this crystal
alien
and whenever she did this
he would freeze or something like this
and people would freeze she could freeze
the room it was a ah that's a raven no
no no no no that hers was the mind yeah
and now i dream of jeannie oh yeah it
was but i dream jenny wouldn't like yeah
you know yeah
that's what she did you don't talk about
i don't i don't
i want to so badly man if anyone
listening to this episode figures out
it was a blonde white girl
as it was a blonde white girl
and she had it wasn't blossom blossom
wasn't blonde from powerpop though no it
was a tv show in the 90s gosh
and i know this girl had a superhero
[ __ ] girl she did this
like a chinese finger trap she did
something i don't know if it was this or
this or something weird people would
freeze but her dad was like this crystal
alien
not blossom still
awesome he said not blossom and then you
said like the power puff girl you ever
seen that show meatball you ever you
ever seen where is that
no no not like you guys wow
whoa i said wow
yeah i don't think i've watched that
either yeah cat and i are yeah no but
cat no cat knows a lot of like i know a
lot of older stuff because uh i used to
spend time in my grandparents room when
i didn't want to socialize with my
family members at family parties and
they'd only have channels one through i
think it was like 14. so i'd watch like
two and a half men [ __ ] on rerun all the
time as a child two and a half men crazy
show that was a shout out i had a strong
run mm-hmm how long did it last after
when ashton kutcher came in i think i
think it only lasted yet like a few
seasons two or three with ashton kutcher
but was it just like yeah it was just
one of those things where it was done
and they were trying to save it but
charlie sheen was kind of the star he
was you really can't
replace charlie sheen in that sort of he
had a nice run though yeah it had a
great run with him it's just
it's weird replacing a main character in
his show
with someone else i had to do it yeah
you had to do it
and look at how that's what happened
you had a great two seasons
but now it's time to uh
it's time to move on
funny you know magic no just imagine
two and a half men with both ashton and
charlie that's essentially what fire the
kid was yeah for a second
no i don't think so i think it just
ended up
coming to a standstill remember that
period of time with him because he was
like winning i'm a winning
winning tiger blood
gosh he was on one got like a hundred
million dollars to leave the show or
some [ __ ] yeah it's something is that
why he said winning
uh
that would make sense never put that
together i know uh
she was 12 seasons though should we see
if we're smarter than this child yeah
let's see let's see man
and how are we going to choose who goes
up against her
uh we're going to spin this wheel that
i've been wanting to use got it
and it we get to get two of us
versus just her exactly
because we need a handicap and i think
it'll be funny if there's fights amongst
you about what the answer is
uh
is that for us it's really hard to do
everybody's initials because there's so
many c's
cat chin and christian but
chappelle meatball chin
yes oh the other t is just existing
oh no and then it just everybody
everybody's in there three times yeah so
t is captain right yeah t is me okay
that's what it is
this is gonna be this is what they're
going to post in front of the kid once
chappelle is gone officially
[Laughter]
well when we left they brian did say you
were going to die i think this is what
we're just going to superimpose your
face on it
that's literally what this is literally
how they did that mm-hmm that's clever
oh that's funny that's funny all right
let's uh let's do it oh yeah we're gonna
spin the wheel once they're okay
i'm still waiting for her to join the
room oh guys i got a tattoo i'm starting
my sleeve and it hurts so bad and i know
it looks like i didn't i didn't show it
to uh anyone on the podcast yet do you
guys want to see it kind of
look i got a food dog fire i mean that
that's fire that's so good gosh that's
amazing work it hurts so bad about the
what it's called a fu dog a food dog
yeah and he has a little bell i had half
of mine to put butter as his name in it
but then i didn't do it what is the
origin of the food dog it is a
like
a chinese symbol for like a guardian
someone like people have statues of it
in front of their houses to protect the
household oh it's like asian gargoyles
yes asian gargoyle that's exactly what
it is
best way
to explain that absolutely it's an asian
gargoyle yeah that's tight like if you
watch mulan do you remember remember
when mushi was supposed to wake up
he's supposed to wake up all the statues
and he was supposed to wake up a
guardian that was gonna take care of
mulan like he wasn't supposed to do it
yeah uh but then it was supposed to be
the fu dog but then the food dog did not
come out and mushu ended up taking the
spot as the guardian damn i want a food
dog now
mega man
oh i love that song the music in mulan
was so good
christina aguilera reflection was that a
girl worth fighting for
yes that's the one
that's amazing
all right let's see how long did that
take uh this took about eight hours i
have two more sessions that will set
eight hours yeah eight hours straight
uh it hurt so bad and i really want
numbing cream but my tattoo artist said
it doesn't really help and it changes
the
like texture of your skin while they're
tattooing so she's like no let's not do
that i'm very nervous because this
this area hurts like a [ __ ] oh yeah
it's terrible i did the elbow perfectly
fine this i cannot do crying throwing up
bri like cannot imagine
i think that's a christian song too
crying
no i can only imagine oh i cannot oh
okay that makes more sense
we both thought we both got current
throwing up
[ __ ] are you ready
what's up are you ready for this if i
get picked i'll just try my best
that's truly all i don't know
an answer i'm going to try my yeah i'll
just yeah i'll just
give it a shot i'll give it a shot i'm
trying my best
i think we're all going to lose badly
oh my god yeah there's no win here yeah
you heard what brian said about us
we're not educated
all right perfect
we're we're doing it
okay
oh i'm so intimidated right now
what's not going to be working what's
next
what do you mean what's not everywhere i
don't know just like
leave little faith hi
can you hear me
hey can you hear us can you hear us
uh can you say something
hello there we are okay we're cool all
right we get here we can hear you
hi marilyn's father
hey what's going on can you you can see
us
i can't see you guys
i can see uh chen
and nick yeah you guys is he happy
yeah sweet yeah okay
here we go yeah there's everybody okay
cool there we go
uh all right uh maylene maylene
everybody else had it we really
appreciated the voice note uh thank you
yeah um so
uh sir uh introduce yourself and your
daughter
here
hello i'm eric this is melon
and uh yeah i heard the podcast and uh
she's about a fifth grader
and so uh
reached out wanted to uh
see what we could do and she's she's
she's quite credentialed pre-ap
uh
volleyball
uh so i'm well nervous i'm legitimately
so nervous right now i i'm like shaking
i don't know why i did not go to a good
public school like i don't think i'm
gonna do well
we're gonna spin the wheel for which two
people she plays in the room i can't
play because they made the game uh but
yeah you're gonna face a team and
honestly
making the questions i feel like it's
gonna be stuff uh you know and they
don't
it's gonna it's gonna be it's gonna be
it's gonna be close
if possible eric the last question would
require a pen and paper
okay
uh there's ten and we can kind of fly
through okay it's gonna be me and uh
awesome
uh it's cat and
the two of us i think we have a third of
a functioning brain
that's being generous and that's being
generated so i'm very nervous all right
here it goes okay
all right the first question is first
grade grammar oh
shoot
and uh do you know this is my second
language i don't know this all right
she's my first but i'm still not great
at it
you guys need pen and paper we're gonna
need a good paper oh yeah because she'll
give her an answer and then they'll have
written theirs down oh you can just
write
they have to write theirs down okay cool
got it all right meatballs grabbing the
pen and paper but do you want to answer
uh malen uh wait wait wait they have to
write this down you answer oh okay
yes
bailey how are you sorry are you nervous
i'm pretty dude
i i think she i think she's like i think
she'll judge after the first question
yeah i think she's like once she sees
the first dance she's like oh i got this
she's like oh these guys are yeah
as soon as this first answer yeah pops
up
also thank you so much for taking the
time out of your uh busy schedule for
this i know you have better things to do
we clearly don't um
but we're trying our best
uh this is the last week we could get
her like i said volleyball starts next
week so here we go okay
i don't like nick's evil laugh now i'm
even more worried all right
so no one's saying anything out loud
they're just gonna write down their
answer yeah
uh actually we'll we'll have you pick
between these two uh subjects and we'll
only do five questions i have two
questions for each grade okay uh uh and
we'll just alternate
cat and meatball would you like music
who gets to pick the subject
uh cat and uh meatball would you like
music or grammar you're both going to
have the same question you guys are just
picking the category this time can i saw
you
do you have any music ability oh we
would have to sing no no like do you
know anything about music you know what
grammar her confidence just went uh
grammar by that i'm
i don't think mac miller is on this you
don't know that okay that's fair i'm
just kidding so i do grammar grammar
yeah let's go grammar great i'm screwed
okay uh so you guys uh true or false
you guys write yours down she'll answer
first okay true or false there are
exactly two nouns
in the following sentence
good call cat cody has a goldfish that
was born in california
cody has a goldfish that was born in
california
true or false
they're exactly
you said true
false
false
you guys i also said false
false false it is there are three nouns
oh thank god these are all exact
questions
taken off of jeff foxworthy's version of
are you smarter than a fifth grader
shout out to jax foxworthy yeah i also
put false weird
you answered late
to be honest you guys should be like
talking amongst yourselves before you
answer yeah also should we have
should we have her say the answer first
or should we all just do the so you know
what i'm saying should we do the paper
thing because then
what if she's right and then like we're
like oh that sounds right and then go
off her i think you're supposed to write
the
answer first and i i flipped it
she should be writing it down you guys
talked to monk amongst each other
decided to answer she had already
written
you possibly have your pen
she's like she's sitting here like we're
definitely
i'm telling you if we all got this far
in life not being able to play a game
you're gonna take over the world
this is no competition
okay
oh my gosh okay chappelle's starting to
hurt my feet
all right
second grade okay uh mailing
amazing
would you like math or
geography
math
okay
so again eric eric and uh you guys do
you have pen and paper
yes sweet okay so you write your answer
down
okay and let us know when you have it
locked in
right now okay
uh oh i haven't asked them oh
[Music]
nick you're making me nervous
this is perfect
uh
what is the fewest number of current u.s
coins you'd need to make exactly 99
cents
wait what say that again what is the
fewest number
of coins okay us coins you would need to
make exactly 99 cents number of points
right right you have to you have to make
99 cents in coins in the fewest amount
of coins
yeah
oh you already have your answer now
no no oh okay
yeah yes
do i write it or do it yeah just write
it
write it and they're gonna talk about it
okay
look at people trying to write
i'm trying to like
trying to do math and
crap
that clip when you go
she's like i'm smart and all these
people is gonna
um
my palms are sweaty i know knees weak
yeah
arms are heavy uh oh you have you you
have yours written down
yeah i have it right now okay they're
gonna they're gonna now talk amongst
each other and give their answer first
so that's how they're gonna do the game
okay well break down the math that you
did
and then i'll break down about that
right
yeah because we're gonna answer or just
yeah just discuss yeah what were your
respective answers and then
you guys can kind of be like no this is
because how many did i say yeah what did
you say i said
eight
what no no nine nine nine nine
i put three quarters for seven hey
what what
it's okay
yeah keep going
what do you what do you keep three
quarters 75 cents yeah two dimes 95
cents four pennies thank god i also got
that
okay so we are at they said nine nine
and you guys said
nine answer is nothing answers oh yes
all right and we are about to we're
we're cruising now we we gotta go
everybody we got them everybody's got
pen and paper it is one to one and they
do get harder third so uh cat and
meatball would you like third grade math
or third grade literature literature
uh okay i'm good the question is
what was the pen name of author charles
doc dodge
dodge you can't even pronounce it they
hello
great question
i don't even know what a picture alice's
adventures in wonderland
charles dodgkin who wrote alice's
adventures in wonderland wait what was
that
what was the pen name of author charles
dodgskin open names
so alice's adventures in wonderland so
basically who wrote alice in wonder uh
wonderland like his stage name yeah
okay
i thought she was good at literature
well i didn't know he was asking me
people's aliases
also
side note how often do you read what
because i don't read that's why i don't
know why you pick literature i do okay
that's fair i just read that
did you ever answer written down or do
you have your answer
no answer
yeah what third grader knows this
they i don't know
okay so
do we answer now or
yeah uh
do do you have an answer charles dicken
i don't know
i really don't know i don't know i took
the guess of charles bukowski
where'd bukowski come from
honestly charles dickens i'm just
kidding
it's louis carroll it's lewis carroll
lewis carroll carol so two two two two
did you know that
melon louis carroll no okay oh thank you
okay cool hey cj in school right
mayland
would you like fourth grade history
or fourth grade science
science
which of the following trees is
considered a conifer
a oak b pine or c maple
which of the following trees is
considered a conifer oh that's easy oak
pine or maple
okay
okay you have yours written down
you guys can discuss amongst yourselves
what were the options
see what that multiple choice does
okay
what do you guys think
pine
um
i honestly don't know and my first
reaction was to go with oak
however if i'm being honest the way i do
these like bubbled questions if i don't
know i always answer c because it's in
the middle
i don't come on now
that's od truth i'm gonna let you take
okay we're going to go with pine
the answer is pine
oh yeah where'd she get you got it right
yes yes you got it right three three
three we're going to the the fifth
question thanks she knew that
she was so that long
she's like she's like did you do that
long time no
like
you don't know
the conifer or whatever what was it we
both have kind of us together we have
the brain of one sixth grader
that's that's progress i mean
i think that's pretty good i'm just
gonna pick the history one okay uh on on
this fifth one wait what's the other
option uh
i think you will both get the other one
okay and there's a chance being generous
very generous open and we haven't done
history opened in 1821
the santa fe trail began in the city of
independence
in what u.s state oh that's easy i know
that independence why do i know that
i know that that's easy oh my god the
city of independence
oh my god
in the usa
do you have an answer
this your quiz um
where is santa fe located first and
foremost arizona
oh santa oh is that it
is the oregon trail started in portland
is in santa fe in new mexico i don't
know she already has her answer
santa fe is new mexico i'ma go with your
answer
uh he says new mexico you have yours
written down uh are we at are we trying
to figure out what's saying say your
reason
new mexico
it's missouri what
oh okay
huh that makes it in santa fe cool
so uh math question i actually would
have got that wrong i was talking really
confident
what were you gonna say
new mexico
actually we're gonna do a tiebreaker
who's ever closest you're confident so i
thought was arizona because you're from
arizona
what year
was the spanish armada
two
this is a fifth grade question and we're
just gonna go who's ever closest so you
have to like throw out a number uh to
tie break it because it's
but is it what grade 3
what what grade is this for the question
bam dude these fifth graders were smart
you got your answer
yeah yeah
do you have an answer 1858 um i guessed
1892. let's go with yours okay cool
1892.
you end
i said 1871.
she wins it's 14.88
oh that's good you guys are not none of
us especially me are smarter than sixth
graders
again she is in pre-ap
i feel like we have a stiff competition
but can we go out on a limb and say that
christian and i together are as smart as
a fifth grader because she's in sixth
grade and she beat us by one question so
like if logistically you had to rate us
are we whatever helps you sleep at night
i guess
it would that's the thing i'm asian so
like i need good grades to a certain
extent um
so it's gonna help me sleep yeah cat's
family's not gonna speak to her for like
six months after this oh absolutely not
i'm not
thank you for being here and watching us
struggle through these questions that
you clearly know so much faster than us
you guys can thank jeff foxworthy
well we really appreciate you joining us
i'm going to reach out to eric and we're
going to get you something i don't know
if you want king in the sting merch uh
but that's all i have uh free access to
but
we'll get some sort of a prize uh but
yeah you want some pencils like pencils
like a pencil you want a traper keeper
what about an xlr cord
a protractor
you make great circles kids like these
huh this is a toy anything you want to
say uh
on your sets you won shout outs
shout out to the volleyball team yeah
shout out to the volleyball team
shout out volleyball uh
no air because she's so smarter than us
you're like i gotta say to y'all
she wrecked us she's here to help us not
the other way around
uh well maybe i'll hammer out some kinks
and we'll rematch it sometime a lot
smoother but
we really appreciate the time thank you
so much volleyball so next time next
time next time a kid challenges us
man is going to be our tutor yeah
to help us with this competition we need
her on payroll
thank you thank you guys so much guys
yeah thank you
good luck on your volleyball game
so funny
i'd just like to apologize to everybody
especially uh moline or man
think about mailing a package or mailing
i know people named uh moline
there's a big moline family from
the midwest from la crosse
and then uh met so it's maylene acker
yeah melin no
she'll tutor us to get it eventually
i'll chop that up so i won't look as bad
and that'll that'll play real nice i
think
just a sizzle wheel of us
doing terrible guesses the literature uh
question oh yeah that was right i was
like you got this [ __ ] you can get it
out
what third grader knows that though that
is a different one like huh like the
author of alice in wonderland i don't
think that's that crazy but his pen name
what's his real name
charlie
the question is basically who's the
author of
alice in wonderland
uh what's his alias
pretty much yeah everybody yeah
that was a super tough one
i mean i don't even know the rapper
future's real name like i don't even
like i don't know
and ailee says she's hard yeah that's
fair but yeah we are not smarter than a
fifth grader definitely not six struggle
but next week if we or not next week but
whenever we do this again
our will christian and i also still be
up or are you and chin and nick up for d
like by default i think chin and i will
yeah we can make chin and i uh by
default see what yeah i got i got my use
of the wheel yeah
and then after those yeah after those we
can rearrange the teams yeah with the
wheel
with the wheel we'll always incorporate
the wheel yeah
uh and i'm sending the zoom link to
george right now but uh
i wonder how far he's gotten so far
because he started driving how many days
ago do you know where he was gonna stay
because he said he's 70 miles from his
hotel
who's george uh george george uh harris
oh george is that because we have a
george here too yeah we have
armenian
yeah
i think armenian because he's from
glendale that's why that's fair that's
fair i think that's a fair very fair
very fair i think that's fair yeah any
kind of looks armenian too
but
yeah are you anywhere on the road this
week
no this week i have off i'm just
chilling what do you do on your week
weekends off
i it's usually like
nick he said
uh usually stuff
with the band or i'm always with toby
nobody's like the person i
inhibit his family i kick it with like
all the time
um because we live right next to each
other toby's the greatest um but yeah
this so this weekend i'll go to his
band's playing in jersey in rhode island
and so i'm gonna go out are you a roadie
wait no just hang just you said he's
going you're going to rhode island this
weekend too yeah
without me without you yeah
i wanted your first experience to be
with me
oh
that's sweet that's and gross yeah why
chin oh the way you said it bro just to
be with me
yeah hey man you guys have a connection
about like finish the sentence your
first yeah i want your first experience
in rhode island
to be with a real rhode island person
your first time it's going to be shitty
right you gave me your first time
george i'm still waiting on him to join
did you switch the
oh back yeah huh
yeah yeah he's gonna join any second
yeah
wait a second there you go b-ball um why
did it do this though then
when i ended the meeting oh you ended
the meeting then we got to send him a
new invite it's all good my bad it's all
good
oh
are you talking about the whole meeting
oh there we are
[Music]
it doesn't look great it doesn't look
like you ended it did you oh you did
you look great
[Music]
you look thrilled to be here thrilled to
be here yes absolutely
i'm just excited for the lighting to be
honest
it's good lighting it is really good see
i can never tell you that you don't know
how to light people of color anymore
it's as bright as it goes
yeah he's like he's like
if
this doesn't work then i don't know i
don't know
we'll do it outside yeah we'll do it
outside yeah we'll get an outside
podcast the break of dawn yeah
cats after dark in the light
[Laughter]
you got a meatball i'm just texting him
the invite from nick's computer right
now
oh you could text like that um i don't
know if that worked
because this is not delivered
it says what you can't uh
text george on there uh
send me it
can you text me it
i'll send it to me from your laptop so
it'll be in your text yeah jim will you
go fishing again
supposed to go for a friend's birthday
but i'm not sure like may 2nd
fishing's kind of like year-round
yeah yeah yeah whatever season
especially here because
we don't freeze over anything but even
the places where dustfree's over they go
ice fishing
so yeah yeah
but didn't you ask chappelle that
because he needs stuff to do when he's
on the road yeah you want to go fishing
out of my mind
you were telling me earlier that you
like going to go fishing did i say that
no i was no i was joking because chin
was in there i got a home uh
his cousin
uh they're out in like newport beach or
whatever
he'll do that uh
deep sea fishing yeah but he does it
with the with the spear yeah oh damn oh
that's gnarly yeah i wouldn't want to do
that he could like get down there
that's scary man yeah that's scary yeah
well i do not trust any freaking body of
water well lakes i don't mind but
oceans there's no way i'm getting that's
where you put all the bodies yeah no you
don't want to
he said you got me man
you don't want to act like aquaman for a
little bit stop scoring some fishes
hell no [ __ ] that water oh i saw jason
momoa in person at a billy eilish
concert because he was bringing his uh
daughter
and the entire yeah he has two younger
kids with uh lisa bonay they had kids
together yeah they did i did not know
that mm-hmm
they're about like 10 or 11 it seems
like but the entire crowd started
chanting jason momoa's name while we
were there and i was just looking at him
from afar like this is the closest i'll
ever be to call drogo because i am a
huge game of thrones fan i just i
absolutely
[ __ ] love jason momoa
he's a big dude big oh my god like
like
i don't know for certain if he's roughly
around mark harley's size because he was
so far away but that's what i would
imagine yeah all
right he's taller than mark harley yeah
oh you got him yep so we're going to add
jordan right now
he says he's joining
there we go
hey george
damn as he's driving too recording in
progress
what up george
what's going on hey guys what's up
nothing much how's the drive
oh you know it's the midwest a lot of
fields a lot of grass
oh it's beautiful what day uh travel day
are you on currently
i'm day one day one about nine this
morning and where are you now
in missouri somewhere
in missouri that's where the santa fe
trail started yeah
[Laughter]
i should go to a bass pro shop huh yeah
yeah they got them out there
um
so george uh
you of course we met you on king and the
sting
uh
you
had just had bmi surgery after losing a
hundred pounds you lost about 200 more
and now you have a job with thick boy
yeah
right right talk about the covers it up
pretty well
yeah uh i just forgot my one l on my
record phoebe
the one l the one l but you're coming
back for revenge
yeah we're gonna tell you where should
be listed
it almost looks like he's stationary
because this is so blue oh i know yeah
it doesn't look like he's moving at all
yeah
so so how long you got you said you're
almost to your hotel first stop of the
night and then
when you get here so what i'm doing
i get there on like the end of the day
the 30th so i'll be actually there for
the first
but uh yeah i'm just doing structure
rules and not trying to drive over like
eight hours a day because i don't want
to die before i make it
nice smart smart smart you gotta pace
yourself yeah yeah oh yeah slow and
steady wins the race
uh
are you seeing any sights on your way
out
uh you know like the the world's largest
gift shop and all that kind of fun stuff
i'm a stockholm
where that is i don't
need anywhere else
we're excited for your arrival yeah man
hey
i know dude
i know i feel like i won the [ __ ]
lottery make the wish or something you
know
like
like i literally said this is my
favorite podcast like i'm not trying to
be like an ass kisser but like this is
my life i sit and i enjoy
your guys's freaking content and now i
get to be a big part of it or at least
the biggest part is you guys me
yes
yeah yeah and and there's no gifts i
mean like you contributed to it it's
like an awesome storyline great dude
tells the story you work hard for it
it's [ __ ] i don't know it's dope how
it worked out yeah yeah it is
that that uh when you came in in the
singlet on king of sting and oh that was
a moment face to face with stevie that's
my favorite
just my favorite moment
close to
uh when your dad walked in uh even great
moments yeah that was those are fun i
like surprise arrivals
it's me versus chappelle's dad next week
on the podcast
[Laughter]
he's producing already
well we love it and can't wait to see ya
uh he'll be in studio next yeah
yeah
we'll have him sit down for the
yeah yeah absolutely for when he gets
here for our when we record the next
episode and then we'll have your father
come into and then we'll get that going
yeah pass after dark fight club
he owed me he first ruled the fixed boy
fight club don't talk about [ __ ] sick
there you go
there we go
well man uh good luck safe travels
yeah
uh whoever information keep them updated
on your
uh drive and stuff make sure you're good
yeah
okay i got you guys i will thank you
guys for being my friends don't be
getting horses don't be tooting around
now with any of those truck stops right
don't go looking for a lot losers yeah
i i have brandish and send the money
over for me he'll reimburse me
all right george bye george
yeah all right have a good show guys
do you think long lizards are a tax
write-off what is a lot i wonder oh a
lot lizard uh so theo came up with the
term right or is was it already a real
thing oh so it's uh women who prostitute
themselves at
trucker stops
people who prostitute themselves
[Laughter]
that's the exact way
that's the exact way i talked to my uh
younger brother he's 11. whenever he
asks me like a real ass question that's
the best way i can put to him like well
they're prostitutes and prostitutes or
women or men who um
women or men they
do
sexual things for money and it's like
what is sexual things like well
ask your mother
and how you got here and um she's
probably not gonna tell you because she
didn't tell me i found that out on my
own but um and your folks are in san
jose yeah in san jose okay i always get
mixed if they're in orange county or san
jose uh san jose my dad's side of the
family is in orange county
yep orange county westminster what's
good
right now it's all the way around but
yes that's how you do it there you go
yeah i almost switched my hand
like a crab
yeah i wonder if that's a get like a
gang sign okay i don't think anyone in
orange county is throwing up o.c i don't
think so either but i do i think that a
bunch of bikers
irvine crips are crazy really
the disney
the disneyland bloods yeah yeah
everyone's like so nice
like the the safest city in all of
america i believe google that really i
don't know if it is currently it was a
few years ago yeah yeah irvine is super
safe super yeah google's nice and very
super in america it better say lacrosse
wisconsin
i know do you remember that wedding
video we saw it is not lacrosse
wisconsin
is not that rochester minnesota that's
only 90 minutes for me
hmm
oh sunnyvale is in the bay area it's
close by san jose santa clarita that
that's really nice
let's look at the top
100 new york wow that's number one
so these are the top 10 for right now i
thought if i would be up there but you
got one i thought everybody would be up
there too
i used to be told all the time that's
why a lot of people from san jose wanted
to send their kids to uci because it was
a good school and also in a very safe
little city yeah everyone's like
pretty much enough so i do remember this
now so uci right across the street an
asian gang pulled a gun on me and my
friends at east or near uci so yeah not
the the safest but would you guys safe
yeah what'd you do they pulled guns
no what were y'all doing you're victim
blaming me no we're literally hanging
out at like a coffee shop what are you
wearing
we didn't look we kind of looked like a
coffee shop we parked our cars
vietnamese hoodlums i think we're gonna
go racing so we're all cars are there oh
you're playing tokyo drift
no we don't we do uh drag racing we
don't do all the turns and stuff like
that
oh it's just a straight shot yeah but
we're like nah we're cool man we're not
gangsters
and then we look for them afterwards and
then they were like all right
and that's
so wait they just wrote up and said hey
what's up and you were like oh they
looked they thought we were gangsters so
they automatically just came up with
guns like what's up where you from like
dude we're not from anywhere but then my
freaking friends fixing this tire
because it sounds so silly to me they're
like but they mutter [ __ ] you man they
look dangerous
that's what it sounds like but they do
exactly it's just like it's so adorable
to me they sound dangerous
come
that's what it sounds like and it's so
adorable i say anyone that's not as
they're saying [ __ ] your mother yeah
and i'm gonna kill you if you get
offended by a [ __ ] mother that's
that's so elementary yeah yeah and these
men are usually like five six oh they
are yeah vietnamese men are usually
short
that's why it's funny there's got to be
a famous tall vietnamese dude google uh
famous
hey man he's not vietnamese i feel like
there are occasions
every time he's like japanese like
i know right chinese i feel like the the
famous people aren't also tall like the
tall vietnamese people are not famous
they keep to themselves i feel like
google tall vietnamese man
orisha
i think there are only like yao ming yao
means chinese chinese and he's what
seven
three
he's another something crazy like that i
think so yeah and he was bread
bread in a lab right in a lab
he was a designer baby
it's yummy
jesus christ
what is uh
2.57 meters so how much is that in feet
i do not know
oh damn
that is wild oh man okay that guy has to
have had been made in a lab as well the
communists
he's got to be the all-time tallest
person
oh my god wait
well he's going to die young
go back well he's both fine
look at that tallest person ever was
vietnamese oh my god
i think so it's just that tallest man
ever
oh my lord wasn't all andre the ma uh
giant the tallest no he's a no he's a
7-4 this guy's 8-4
ever ever
titan living
i remember that dude
don't they have him in like the guinness
book of world records
robert waldo he was eight feet oh holy
sh
eight feet eleven inches oh my god okay
he's got
mister
damn he didn't have that long or a run
though he only died at 22.
that's i thought he couldn't walk in the
toilet
i wonder if now because of like modern
medicine modern medicine and all this
stuff i wonder like he he probably could
have he probably could survive now
we'll look at great danes great things
don't live that long
their hips give out but still that's not
the tallest person alive is what we were
looking for to see if it was that
vietnamese man this guy died in 1962.
wait how how did
robert waldo uh
i know i kind of want to god yeah i kind
of want him he's like 22 years old yeah
that's why i kind of want to see
adulthood and death
he required leg braces that sucks oh god
he never used a wheelchair wheelchair oh
i heard there's a procedure where you
can break your legs and they'll like try
to extend it yeah
i already looked into that it's like
eight grand per leg i feel like that's
so it's a deal for freaking getting
taller
to break both of your legs and then put
a metal rod in it i don't know if i like
you tall
oh
yeah thank you
yeah
that was a compliment i'm just i'm
saying like your height is your height
like let it be i i just don't know if i
could do it with the whole like metal
frogs in my [ __ ] legs and [ __ ] that
just be annoying because then you have
to deal with it in your legs for the
rest of your life you go through a metal
detector and it goes off it's just
my uncle he uh went to vietnam for a
surgery and because like he had been
injured while he was in vietnam yeah and
he had surgery while he was there and
they put a metal like a piece of metal
in his collarbone that's still there to
this day so anytime he goes through a
metal detector he has to explain to
people like oh it's actually my collar
bone like if you use the machine like
you can see it right here oh damn yeah
sultan kozin so is he
what is eight eight feet two point he's
living inches two eight inches
but a vietnamese guy must be dead this
guy this guy died from a faulty brace
that irritated his ankle leading to an
infection he was treated with a blood
transfusion in surgery but his condition
worsened due to an autoimmune disorder
and he died in his sleep on july 15th
his coffered coffin was measured at 10
feet 9 inches
it's a big hole to dig uh what who do
you want me to look up what was the name
uh no i i was just saying who the
tallest ever you have to look it up uh
it's so funny uh i don't know
what instincts george texted me after we
ended the zoom and he said don't forget
your guys's magic mind oh my god
no i didn't forget i have uh it queued
up on my laptop ready to go sick sick
but uh
come on nick you need that magic mine i
know that's the problem right we didn't
have it
yeah i want to embarrass myself in that
game
[Music]
all right if we had the magic mind it
would have been good we just keep this
we had the magic mine cat and i would
have been smarter than a sixth grader
i'd like to think back
chappelle just dome shot him
oh
thank you
i didn't see it i was just
like
hey i'm feeling good
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah so that was the once daily elixir
the anti-procrastination drink get it
magic mine dot co slash dark promo code
dark for 25 percent off
and it's delicious get your ashwagandha
in you
i like it more every time
me too
start craving the taste after a while
i actually saw it
i tried to let that go but relax but
i
are you having intrusive thoughts
[Laughter]
that's good
should we plug some stuff get out let's
watch some stuff man
hey
yeah you'll see me around
on cats after dark in chappelle's world
that's where you'll find me consistently
now
i mean i've always consistently been
here but uh that's where i'll be and
also i would love for you guys to come
see me on the road um san diego
i mean i feel like we have a lot of san
diego fans right yeah yeah message me
san diego say you're a fan or something
tell them some things to do may 7th uh
i'll be in mike drop comedy club new
comedy club i'm doing the grand opening
weekend of the club get those tickets uh
and then also may 12th i'll be doing a
one-nighter
in the hometown of uh phoenix at stand
up live and then
meatball june 24 the 25th rhode island
at the comedy connection tickets at
chapellelacey.com
and also check out chappelle's world on
facebook youtube and all audio platforms
thursdays 3 p.m yep
you know where to find me
yep
we're going to be rolling deep to your
shows i want you to know that
oh you know oh you're going to have a
bunch of like you make scumbags you make
them buy tickets of course
the only person i probably won't i won't
make any money
the only people i might have you cop is
just my parents and my grandfather if
that's fine
hey my grandfather 100 like that oh he
is yeah he honestly might do that if i'm
being real with you i don't know i love
i love the italian culture love it oh
you're going to be experiencing a lot of
it yeah
like maybe too much yeah
yeah love it yeah awesome
i'm gonna get you some you're gonna
break your vegan uh veganism for a
little bit yeah you will
if you wanna experience it yeah you will
yeah well if i wanna experience i'll
experience what i experienced i'll just
look at something next oh
yeah hi it's me you can find me and my
feet on onlyfans.comteen
and my instagram at teen yeah cool
um so just the same thing i'm sure you
wouldn't play the same thing but
brendan's special you guys probably saw
by now the thick boy album's gonna be
out by now and then me chappelle
uh mad peaceful his band and little
brows are gonna perform in the
troubadour may 17th it's in la so come
out and support we'd love to see you
classic venue too yeah
it's a tuesday too
they live in tents right that's what
even huh nothing limited
uh watch uh or listen to another below
deck podcast and watch it actually the
editing is really fun we have
brian who's on here once he edits it and
makes it really funny and uh if you
watch the netflix dating shows loves
blind or ultimatum uh absurd shows cover
those on my patreon
patreon.com session another podcast
network okay
um
instagram see palo 6 tiktok
christian.paolo um
you can also chin already plug brandon
special so
uh you can i'm gonna do a recommendation
uh it's a show i've been watching on
netflix it's a foreign show it's called
how to sell drugs online fast it's
really good
it's really good interesting i like the
name i like it yeah it's like kind of
like a not gen z it's like a younger
generation like where they do it all
over the phone kind of it's like a
foreign power almost
yeah wow
yeah so that's it
all right cool well
thank you guys for tuning in to another
episode of cats after dark and we'll see
you next week see you next week bye
see you later
[Music]
[Music]
foreign